benvenuti sanità stories anzi bentornati
solita store
oggi nuovo episodio credimi ma come
potete vedere siamo all'aperto ed è
notte
non so se sarà ancora più difficile
perché magari i suoni della natura che
busseranno i miei movimenti delle funi e
magari crimini riusciranno
speriamo comunque questo è il terzo
episodio perché lo scorso episodio il
secondo episodio ha raggiunto i 50 60
mila mi piace sia anche il quarto
episodio e fateci sapere poi nei
conventi dove volete che sia ambientato
in che situazione e sociale consigliato
di farlo all'aperto quindi non è tenuto
martedì rimi alberto infatti créme alle
3 di notte e speriamo di non spaventarsi
troppo da g però io ti ho anche un
aiutante indovinate chi
oggi c'è merlino che mi aiuterà
speriamo che mi avvisi quando prendi
vicino e speriamo che trovi anche lui
gli ingredienti così sarà più facile ma
ho paura che rimarrà a giocare con il
suo giochino tutto il tempo
non mi sembra molto interessato comunque
iniziamo ad esplorare un po e vediamo se
riusciamo a trovare qualche ingrediente
finora non ho visto g il che è positivo
oppure si stanno al governo dentro
qualche angolo di alberi
mi guardate sta passeggiando li mattino
sono nascosta dietro mago merlino fai
silenzio berlino marina scappata marina
quello sì se quindi scappa subito
[Musica]
martino che qua e qua con te chi per
fortuna riesce a scappare molto
velocemente perché è velocissimo
[Musica]
riprendi considerato avvicinarsi perché
sente il rumore di martino quindi è
meglio che non sono comunque mi sto
curando intorno niente marino continua a
correre all'impazzata ragazzi sto
continuando ad andare in giro e ad
esplorare vedere se c'è qualche
ingrediente sly ma finora non ho trovato
niente merlino continua a fare casino
quindi mi sono allontanata dal mio
arrivino altri film arriva subito granny
forse era giusto e qualcosa
guardate mi sembra di vedere qualcosa
su cui siamo se anche voi sembra quasi
una colla ma non sono sicura dopo per
forza avvicinare ok
procedo verso l'albero è un albero una
parla comunque di che remi non c'è
l'ombra ancora se merlino non far rumore
è però ovviamente lui mi segue ok ma
credo ferma col guardate penso che ci
sia una trappola qua penso di riuscire a
prenderla
ok l'ho presa senza problemi per fortuna
ok
controlliamo se c'è qualcos'altro
anche se è un po inquietante perché
lazio è buio pesto
però devo controllare ho paura di
avvicinarmi al cancello
non mi sembra di vedere niente io poi ho
pesto del cancello
non so se dovrei aprire il cancello
o no ho perso un giorno perenni mi ha
beccato e mi ha beccato quasi subito
almeno un'altra volta sono riuscito a
non farmi beccare però se non riuscito a
prenderla la colla che si illumina al
buio
ed è proprio adatta in questa situazione
merlino volesse facendo merli continua
visto che sfottuta bravo dell'altro
[Musica]
troppo casino e berlino fa un sacco di
rumore quindi ancora più difficile
questa sala eccola la vedete dietro
rischio
sta tanto però per ora è lontano
guardate non so se riuscite a vederla
nella zuppa che sorveglia il corridoio
quindi ho paura nel corridoio ma io
provo berlino come sembra che ci sia
niente purtroppo almeno ho preso la
colla aspettavo momento ma che cos'è
questo non si vedeva perché era al buio
ma c'era un match non è proprio un
ingrediente però è comunque utile per
fare lo slime anzi penso che lascerò il
tutto appoggiato qua non penso che credi
verrà a rubarli spero
[Musica]
continuiamo ad esplorare o come il
presentimento ci sia qualcos'altro lì
nel corridoio perché in genere se
clienti stati membri
vuol dire che sono gli ingredienti
berlino continua a fare casino
[Musica]
si no
perché non posso
berlino di qua
la carmatic ha ferito
credimi ha peccato di nuovo perso un
altro giorno perché stavo cercando di
salvare merlino praticamente non so cosa
gli è preso berlino con tiro ancora più
difficile qua fuori di notte comunque
merlino ha iniziato a rincorrere granny
e non so se voleva morderla forse voleva
ucciderla per salvarmi
oppure voleva solo giocare comunque
treni l'avrebbe colpito ma l'ho chiamato
per venire da me e stamparlo ma
ovviamente chiamandolo credimi ha
scoperto quindi d'ora in poi cercherò di
stare lontano da merlino un'ora prima
che premi le casse quest'area devo fare
piano perché tra l'altro ancora più
difficile fuori nella natura perché ogni
passo che poi scricchiola l'erba non è
come stare in casa che non ora quando
cammini sembra di vedere qualcosa lì
guardate
cerchiamo ora un impotente sta in quello
non sono sicuro potrebbe essere una
scatolina normale però è meglio cosa
vecchia a vedere che cos'è tv crimini
non c'è traccia finora sterlino non fa
rumore perché per liquidi forse riesco a
prenderlo o no 66 riuscita a salire
santa fa non riesce ora proprio vada via
ma chi lo sa lui è tranquillo con tra
via sta ancora provando a prendere ma da
qua marras
per fortuna ho trovato questo punto qua
in alto e che vorreste beccarmi ok
sanofi a casa capaci per fortuna
berna fai silenzio
come dire che non è niente cosa che
bicarbonato per fortuna io credo ancora
di questo vostro bond sta aspettando che
essendo da qui sarà molto difficile
scendere con lei che mi aspetta io link
in un bar ce la faccio a scendere da qui
berlino attacca marino attacca attacca
mourinho attacca perché crei di berlino
faccia capire mi berlino ha paura di
rugby beh lo capisco anch'io ho paura di
grendi ragazzi dobbiamo per forza
aspettare che i treni si allontani
altrimenti non riusciamo mai a scendere
da qui senza essere beccata e purtroppo
che eni sta aspettando che io scenda da
qui la riprova a fare silenzio non so se
gremi cidade bene sinceramente a me
sembra che ci veda un po male ma che
sento ha solamente i rumori quindi per
passare in silenzio e magari pensa che
sono andata via d'acqua e si allontana
proviamo
[Musica]
non c'è più
ragazzi non c'è più premi
non so come ha fatto allontanarsi così
in fretta perché mi sono distratta solo
un momento veramente da nessuna parte
marta è andata di là nel corridoio e
penso che ci sia qualche altro
ingrediente la perché sta sempre lì nel
corridoio quindi sentiamo da qua piano
piano senza fare rumore
[Musica]
non c'è traccia di crede ancora che
andiamo verso quell'area
piano piano non so da che la tua andare
in realtà può andare di qua qua non mi
sembra che ci sia niente di interessante
no ken mi ha beccato di nuovo questa
volta mi ha fatto un agguato perché io
pensavo che fosse andata via
mentre a spettacoli quando mi sono
distratta un momento pensavo fosse
andata via in realtà si era
semplicemente nascosta dietro la porta
ecco perché avevano fatto così in fretta
ma ora non mi farei a pu perché starò
super attenta anche perché questo è il
quarto giorno abbiamo solo un altro
giorno a disposizione però per fortuna
abbiamo il bicarbonato quindi sapete
qual è l'unica cosa che manca ancora
detto
premier raggio per fortuna lontano da me
questa pace
vabbè comunque l'unico ingrediente che
manca è la soluzione per me allora mi
manca forse permetti io penso di sapere
molto bene dove nel corridoio nel
corridoio dov'era tre anni lo so e
inquietantissimo quel corridoio però
segreti è sempre lì vuol dire che c'è
qualcosa oppure sta facendo la guardia
qualcosa qualche mostro non so mi avete
detto che ha un figlio due figlie un
nipote bene vedesse nonna dovrebbe avere
un ipoteca il corridoio inquietante
ho paura ad andare figli
[Musica]
guardate cren il laccio sta aspettando
che vado nel corridoio
eccola sta scendendo le scale
[Musica]
io penso che mi voglia fare un altro
agguato anzi ne sono sicura cordate e lì
che aspetta mi sta guardando
eccola lì fa tornando su che sta facendo
merlino barchino ci devo peracchia taqwa
rincorsa fatto quasi
[Musica]
stacca
c'è un possibile percorrere qualcuno
2000 come avete potuto vedere i primi
questo sorveglianza sentito dei rumori e
spazi grandi si sta nascondendo degli
alberi aspettavo che io torni li fai
beccarmi stavolta io non tornerò lì
perché sono sicura che riuscirò beccarmi
e farne un altro agguato
io aspetto qua che lei si sposti
completamente magari che venga da questa
parte così di andarmi corridoio senza
che lei myriad miragica
[Musica]
che cos'è quella cosa
avete visto anche voi soluzione per
lenti ma è troppo in alto come faccio a
prenderla sta solo aspettando che
risalga le scale cioè spero che non
essendo no non c'è il cane non scendere
le scale berlino
per fitto la spagna faccia insieme al
figlio tramonta nando mi faccio vedere
tutta la soluzione impedimenti e proprio
lì o'leary proprio lì come cavano faccia
a prenderla l'unico modo è porgermi da
qua sopra
ma è pericoloso non fatelo a causa
ovviamente proverò ad allungare il
braccio forse riesco mi sembra che però
iniziano le vicinanze
nel lazio ok ce la possa fare
sta rincorrendo berlino quindi da un
lato merlino è utile perché è un
diversivo
eccoli là si annuncia privo non ci sono
quasi ci sono quasi
[Musica]
la fifa sta tenendo il braccio al
massimo ma non ci arrivo da maledizioni
ci riprovo
ciao non ci arrivo è caduta mica
[Musica]
brega
ragazze già fatto questo software per 20
ora mi mancherebbe solo la paletta ma
purtroppo non sono riusciti a trovarla
quindi lo mi schierò non posso con le
mani fatalmente il resto questi eventi
nel mio ripostiglio ecco g razzo
ok mi devo spostare d'acqua è troppo
pericoloso potrebbero scoprirmi che sta
facendo rumore no non dico ok
berlino la distratta per fortuna
[Musica]
ok
sono nascosta
[Musica]
roma
ok ragazzi o tutti gli ingredienti qua
per fare castrare mosse 6 non arriva
granny adesso vinciamo anche questa
volta siamo subito famigliari dei caduti
[Musica]
mente merci ho messo poca colla perché
dovrò attivarlo con le mani quindi
vediamo i fermi poca sono sicura che la
paletta e qua da qualche parte ma non ho
tempo per cercarla perchè è solo un
giorno i treni stavano per beccarmi in
meno come in the soluzione per letti
forse io mi sono troppo va bene così
bicarbonato
fatto e ora mescoliamo con le mani
[Musica]
dopo fresco e un pizzicotto ancora
ragazzi ho le mani tutti appiccicose
devo prendere una foglia per pulirmi
altrimenti non riesco a ad a pensare
bene lo slime quindi mi allontano solo
momento per prendere una follia perle
opportunamente le valli altrimenti
presto aspettatemi quelle torno subito
eccomi qua allora ho pulito le mani e lo
slime praticamente attivo cielo quasi
fatta devo solo mescolarlo ancora un
pochino poco fuoco ragazzi per un pelo
ce l'abbiamo fatta
lo abbiamo rischiato grosso perché
granny ci ha colpito lo stesso ma
essendo lo slime attivo non poteva
vincere doveva scomparire
qui invece l'abbiamo fatta è fila
ragazzi siano più motta ancora un'altra
volta
se non avete visto il video in cui balti
ha nascosto di ingredienti slime
purtroppo in quella sala ho perso e in
un modo assurdo se non l'avete visto
andati a vederlo ora dopo questo video
così potete consigliarmi come riuscire a
superare anche la challenge di baldi
perché quella non sono riuscito a
superarlo ma è sempre è stato super
divertente mi raccomando lasciate un bel
mi piace a 60 mila mi piace ci sarà la
quarta parte e ora ve lasso qua 4
caselline su cui applicare per vedere i
miei altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e andate a vedere la solenne
si ribalti una visione ciao
[Musica]